[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video i'm going to be
discussing the events that transpired
post deathly hallows that is events that
occurred
after the fall of lord voldemort more
specifically
i'm going to be discussing whether or
not the trio hermione granger ron
weasley and harry potter
ever ended up finishing their education
at hogwarts
the 1997-1998 year was an
interesting one it would have been harry
ron and hermione's seventh year
the famed magical school hogwarts and i
say would have been
because the trio ended up spending their
time elsewhere 97 to 98 was the height
of voldemort in the death eater's power
after his second resurgence voldemort
had amassed legions of followers
taking control of the ministry and even
ended up taking hogwarts
things were not looking good in an
effort to end voldemort's oppressive
regime
harry who had recently become aware of
horcruxes knew that it was up to him to
track them down and stop voldemort
hoping to eventually bring back
prosperity to the wizarding world
this meant ditching school entirely for
the year and instead using that time
to track down horcruxes naturally ron
and hermione weren't going to allow
harry to pursue his mission alone
which meant that they joined him in his
search however what this also meant was
that all three of the trio
missed out on their seventh year of
education this poses the question
did they graduate did they finish their
magical education
there is evidence to support that
hermione actually ended up graduating in
which suggests that she ended up going
back to finish but
what of ron and harry did they go back
or
did they have bigger fish to fry it
turns out jk rowling actually answered
this question in an interview
oh speaking of ron and hermione yeah did
they graduate from hogwarts
yes did they harry and ron didn't go
back
hermione did ooh oh my
did you bet right i mean come on
nobody's going to think hermione
wouldn't go back
i predicted yeah of course she'd go back
she has to get her newts
ron was really done with schooling i
think that it would be kind of tempting
to go back just to mess around for a
year
and have a break but he goes into the
aura department
kingsley would have wanted ron neville
harry and they would have all gone
and they would have all done their job
so that would have been rounding up the
corrupt people who were doing lucius
malfoy and trying to pretend that they
really weren't involved
so there you have it neither ron nor
harry ended up returning to hogwarts
but it certainly didn't stop them from
being successful both boys ended up
becoming impressive auras at one point
or another
and it has been reported that harry
would even occasionally return to
hogwarts for a guest lecture
sure they didn't complete seventh year
or write their newts but they did
defeat lord voldemort so that has got to
count for something
and that's it for this video did you
know that these famous boys never
graduated let me know in the comment
section below
until next time let us step into the
night and pursue that flighty temptress
adventure
you